Spoiler alert: Game of Thrones isn't a series
known for its happy endings.
And fans certainly aren't getting many in
the show's final season.
Several major characters met their end in
the fifth episode of season 8, and now the
actor who played Varys has revealed that he
wasn't thrilled with how his story ended.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, Conleth
Hill opened up about the experience of seeing
his character burned to death by the Mad Queen
Daenerys, saying he took it "very personally."
There was some bright side for Hill, though,
as he felt Varys died a "noble" death after
the Master of Whispers revealed to the world
the true parentage of Jon Snow in an attempt
to make sure Westeros had a better ruler than
the vengeful and sadistic Daenerys.
"If he dislikes one monarch, he conspires
to crown the next one.
What kind of servant is that?"
"The kind the realm needs.
Incompetence should not be rewarded with blind
loyalty."
Hill continued,
Still, the death stings, especially considering
how little Varys has been given to do over
the past two seasons.
If you were frustrated by that, well, you're
not alone, as Hill revealed he wasn't too
happy with his character's arc either.
Hill also said that he felt like Varys was
acting out of character in those two seasons,
as the master spy suddenly seemed to have
no idea what was going on, and exerted no
influence over events.
Overall, though, Hill stressed that his experience
on Game of Thrones has been "brilliant."
And he doesn't think fans will be disappointed
with the series finale.
Well…all except one, anyway.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.